actress markie post has died a rep for
the late actress confirmed the news to
e.t on sunday post's death follows a
nearly four-year battle with cancer she
was 70.
how much longer do you think i could do
it i could do it forever she survived by
her husband two daughters and
five-month-old granddaughter
in a statement to deadline her family
said in part but for us our pride is in
who she was in addition to acting a
person who made elaborate cakes for
friends sewed curtains for first
apartments and showed us how to be kind
loving and forgiving in an often harsh
world
post his career spanned over four
decades including her roles on the
well-known tv shows the fall guy in
night court
it's nice to know in this ever-changing
world that you'll always be your
disgustingly perverted self
count on me
night court became a tv phenomenon and
earned multiple emmy awards across its
nine seasons post joined the main cast
in season three hi ted hi mrs jensen how
are you post also played cameron diaz's
mom in the 1998 comedy there's something
about mary
and she recently had a reoccurring role
on chicago pd
sophia bush co-starred with post on the
hit nbc drama sophia tweeted on sunday
i'm just heartbroken at the news of
marky's passing she was a rock a light a
great friend and a phenomenal scene
partner she brought sunshine everywhere
she went prayers there's so few
surprises left you know
poe spoke often with e.t onset of night
court nobody can believe it nobody can
actually believe that it's been 100
shows the fact that the six of us all
like each other so much and we all do
practical jokes on each other all the
time anyway so that by the time we get
to friday night and we're taping the
show anything goes and i think that
shows on the show i think that you can
tell that we're just having a lot of fun
we are
[Music]